There are many words that could be used to
describe Wyatt Earp: fearless gunfighter,
uncompromising lawman, deliverer of frontier
justice.
There can also be a few more words like murderer
or con-man or pimp.
As you are about to see, Wyatt Earp was a
complex character full of features and foibles.
An icon of the Old West?
Undoubtedly, but calling him a “hero”
might be stretching it a bit.
He’s had his good moments, but his life
was also full of questionable actions.
His persona as a paragon of justice in those
wild, ruthless frontier days was carefully
crafted after his death, first by a biography
and then by TV shows, movies, and more books.
Today we will take a look at all the big events
in his life: a 30-second shootout that defined
the Wild West; a quest for revenge taken straight
out of the pages of an adventure novel; a
boxing match that might have shown us that
everyone could be bought for the right price.
Good or bad, these actions helped mold one
of the most captivating and legendary figures
in American history.
Early Life & Family
He was born Wyatt Berry Stapp Earp on March
19, 1848, in Monmouth, Illinois, to Nicholas
Porter Earp and Virginia Ann Cooksey.
Wyatt had eight siblings, including one half-brother
from his father’s first marriage.
However, for the sake of brevity, we will
only single out two brothers for now, Virgil
and Morgan Earp, who became gunslinging lawmen
like Wyatt and were right beside him during
the infamous Gunfight at the O.K. Corral.
Image: Young Wyatt and his mom
https://commons.wikimedia.org/wiki/File:Wyatt-earp-mother.jpg
The family moved around during Wyatt’s childhood,
first to Pella, Iowa, and then to San Bernardino,
California.
When the Civil War broke out, his three older
brothers joined the Union Army.
According to legend, Wyatt also wanted to
join the fight, despite being only 13 years
old at the time.
He attempted to run away and enlist several
times, but his father always managed to track
him down and bring him home.
As a teenager, Wyatt worked various odd jobs,
mainly helping his brothers in driving stagecoaches
and transporting cargo.
He also started gambling around this time,
a lifelong passion of his, and got his first
experience with refereeing boxing matches,
something that will have a huge impact on
his life much later.
Image: Urilla Sutherland
https://commons.wikimedia.org/wiki/File:Urilla_Sutherland.jpg
In his early 20s, Wyatt Earp became a lawman
for the first time.
After a few years of traveling and working
through the West, he settled down and rejoined
his family who, by then, had relocated again
to Lamar, Missouri.
Nicholas Earp was the local constable there,
but in 1869 he resigned his position and Wyatt
was appointed as his replacement.
At that same time, Earp fell in love and married
20-year-old Urilla Sutherland, but their relationship
was short-lived.
She died in 1870, either due to typhoid fever
or childbirth complications.
Downward Spiral
As you might imagine, this loss affected Wyatt
hard.
First, he started neglecting his duties as
a constable.
Presumably, at one point, he was either fired
or he quit his job and spent the next few
years drifting from one city to another, going
from saloon to bar to brothel.
Earp got into a few troubles with the law.
He was accused of horse theft in Arkansas,
was arrested but escaped jail and fled to
Peoria, Illinois.
Here, he reunited with his brother Morgan
and was often reported to be in the company
of a young prostitute named Sally Heckell
who, at times, called herself the wife of
Wyatt Earp.
Going by the charges levied against the Earp
brothers by Peoria lawmen, local authorities
considered the two to be pimps who ran their
own brothel.
It is possible that the brothers also took
up buffalo hunting, although this is poorly
attested.
In fact, the only solid evidence is an entry
in the diary of their young sister, Adelia
Earp.
She wrote that Wyatt and Morgan visited the
family farm on her 11th birthday and brought
her a lot of pretty clothes because they made
“quite a heap of money” by hunting buffalo.
Of course, it is also plausible that this
was a lie so the brothers could hide their
less-than-honorable true source of income.
Lawman Again in Kansas
Earp’s lawman career picked up again in
1874 when he was hired as an assistant marshal
in Wichita, Kansas.
The most memorable event from this period
was a particularly embarrassing one for a
man who built his reputation as a gunfighter.
The young Wyatt Earp discharged his revolver
by accident when he dropped it on the floor
of a gambling house.
The bullet passed through his coat and caused
a quick evacuation of the saloon.
Allegedly, Earp confessed to the incident
to his biographer, Stuart Lake, but asked
that he kept it out of the book.
In 1876, Earp left Wichita and joined the
police force in Dodge City, Kansas, a famed
frontier town during the Wild West.
He stayed there for a few years, except for
a brief spell where he is generally believed
to have traveled to Deadwood, South Dakota,
with his brother, Morgan.
Image: Bat Masterson
Wyatt got into his fair share of scrapes as
a policeman in Dodge City and handled many
of them alongside another noted gunslinger
of the era, Bat Masterson, who we might see
on this channel some day.
In 1877, Wyatt Earp left in pursuit of outlaw
Dave Rudabaugh after the former robbed a railroad
construction camp.
He never caught up to the criminal, but the
chase was noteworthy for a different reason
- Earp met and befriended fellow gambler and
gunslinger Doc Holliday.
Image: Doc Holliday
On another occasion, Wyatt Earp, Bat Masterson,
and several other people got into a gunfight
with a drunken posse that was shooting up
the town.
One of the gunmen named George Hoy or Hoyt
was injured in the shootout and later died
with many historians giving Earp the credit
and touting George Hoy as the first man that
Wyatt Earp killed.
However, there was never any surefire evidence
showing who actually hit him.
Another close call happened around September,
1878, when Ed Morrison and a rowdy posse of
25 other men were causing a ruckus at the
Long Branch Saloon.
Earp went to confront them and was aiming
his gun at Morrison when one of his many compatriots
reached for his own weapon.
Fortunately, he never got a shot off because
he was hit in the shoulder by none other than
Doc Holliday who had since relocated to Dodge
City and was gambling at the Long Branch Saloon
when he stepped in to save his friend.
That is a nice story, but it probably never
happened.
Although Earp did say that Holliday once saved
his life in Dodge City, there are no police
records or newspaper stories of this event
even though the city’s history is, otherwise,
well-documented.
This seems like a good place to mention that
many of these lesser-known anecdotes from
Wyatt Earp’s life come to us from a single
source - the biography of the aforementioned
Stuart Lake titled “Wyatt Earp: Frontier
Marshal”.
Published in 1931, the book was absolutely
instrumental in creating the Wild West persona
of Wyatt Earp that we know today.
However, calling it a “biography” is rather
deceitful since it has about as much fiction
as it does fact.
Image: Colt Buntline Special
A perfect example of this is the Colt Buntline
Special.
This is one of the most famous guns of the
Wild West because it was the gun of Wyatt
Earp and it had a distinctive 12-inch barrel.
However, the only problem is that the gun
did not exist; not in Wyatt’s time, at least.
Lake described the weapon in detail and told
a good story of how it was custom-ordered
by dime novelist Ned Buntline who gave away
five of these to famed Old West lawmen.
It was popular enough to create a long-lasting
myth that still raises doubts today.
Colt eventually did start producing this gun
during the 1950s, because of its popularity
and connection to Wyatt Earp, and today it
is a prized artifact for gun collectors.
Arrival in Tombstone
We got a bit off-track, but it is important
to remember how easy it was to fabricate details
about larger-than-life figures whose exploits
were told mainly through newspaper stories
and pulp novels.
Now let’s get back to the good stuff as
Wyatt Earp and his brothers relocated to the
boomtown of Tombstone, Arizona.
Image: Mattie Blaylock
He did so in December 1879, accompanied by
Mattie Blaylock, a former prostitute who became
his common-law wife.
Tombstone had only been founded earlier that
year once prospectors discovered silver in
the area.
In just several months, the community grew
from 100 or so people living in shacks and
tents to a proper town with over 1,000 residents.
Older brother Virgil Earp was the town marshal
while Wyatt and Morgan worked as private security
by riding shotgun, quite literally, on Wells
Fargo stagecoaches.
Siblings James and Warren Earp also moved
to Tombstone but, for the most part, stayed
out of the gunslinging shenanigans.
Rounding up their little posse was Doc Holliday
who came a little later.
It didn’t take long for the Earps to confront
the Cowboys, a group of outlaws who would
quickly grow to despise them.
Rather than being a traditional gang, the
Cowboys were more of a primitive crime syndicate
active in the Arizona Territory.
They numbered hundreds of members that were
only loosely-affiliated with one another.
For now, we will only mention a few of them
who played prominent roles in Earp’s story.
They were the Clanton brothers, Ike, Billy,
and Phineas; Frank Stillwell, Pete Spence,
Curly Bill Brocius, Frank and Tom McLaury,
Billy Claiborne, and Johnny Ringo.
Tensions kept rising as the two groups had
run-ins with each other.
Things took a serious turn in September, 1881,
when two of the Cowboys, Stillwell and Spence,
robbed a stagecoach on the Sandy Bob Line
to Bisbee, Arizona.
They were arrested by a posse which included
two Earps, but were released.
Virgil Earp arrested them again a few weeks
later, this time on a federal charge of interfering
with a mail shipment.
They were again let go for insufficient evidence,
but this act angered the local Cowboys, particularly
the McLaurys.
They claimed they would kill the Earps if
they tried to arrest them again.
Gunfight at the O.K. Corral
After weeks of threats, the escalating situation
came to a head on October 26, 1881.
That morning, an incident between Wyatt Earp
and Tom McLaury led to the former pistol whipping
the latter for allegedly carrying a concealed
weapon.
Throughout the rest of the day, McLaury gathered
more of his partners and the Cowboys were
seen loitering angrily around town.
According to a recently-passed ordinance,
people had to surrender any deadly weapons
upon entering Tombstone.
Marshal Virgil Earp intended to disarm the
Cowboys and asked Wyatt, Morgan, and Doc Holliday
to assist him.
Five of them had gathered on Fremont Street,
in a vacant lot near the O.K. Corral.
They were Frank and Tom McLaury, Billy and
Ike Clanton, and Billy Claiborne.
At around 3 p.m., the Earps confronted the
Cowboys.
According to his later testimony, Virgil demanded
they surrender their weapons, but two of them
cocked their revolvers.
Then...the shooting started.
It is impossible to say with any certainty
what the exact sequence of events was.
The gunfight at the O.K. Corral lasted no
more than 30 seconds, time during which around
30 shots were fired, filling the lot with
black gunpowder smoke.
At the end, Billy Clanton, Frank and Tom McLaury
were dead.
Ike Clanton and Billy Claiborne were, likely,
unarmed and managed to run away right before
the shooting started.
Virgil and Morgan Earp and Doc Holliday had
been shot, but their injuries were not serious.
Wyatt Earp alone stood unscathed.
Aftermath
Just 30 seconds created the most famous gunfight
in the history of the Wild West, although
newspapers had a heavy influence on how it
was remembered.
For starters, despite its name, it never actually
took place at the O.K. Corral, but rather
next to it.
Also, the whole thing was more Virgil’s
affair rather than Wyatt’s but, for some
reason, the media preferred to focus on the
younger brother.
Maybe it was because he was the one left standing
or maybe this extra attention on Wyatt Earp
was only applied retroactively as he continued
to have more headline-making adventures while
Virgil, for the most part, led a rather unassuming
life from then on.
Either way, one part that usually gets left
out of the story is the legal aftermath that
came following the shootout.
A few days later, Ike Clanton filed murder
charges against the Earps and Doc Holliday.
As Morgan and Virgil were still recuperating
from their wounds, only Wyatt and Holliday
were arrested and brought to court before
Judge Wells Spicer.
There were plenty of testimonies but, unsurprisingly,
they were often contradictory and were dependent
on who the witness sympathized with.
A lot of the focus was on who shot first,
but most sources agreed that the first two
shots which, ostensibly, belonged to Billy
Clanton and Wyatt Earp, happened almost simultaneously.
One historian who carefully compared all the
neutral testimonies concluded that, by and
large, they supported the account put forward
by the Earps that they tried to disarm the
Cowboys and the gunfight erupted at the provocation
of Clanton and Frank McLaury.
Judge Spicer agreed and cleared the Earps
and Holliday of any wrongdoing.
Cowboys’ Revenge
The Earps won the fight, but they knew that
there were other Cowboys out there who would
be looking for revenge.
As a precaution, the brothers moved their
families to the Cosmopolitan Hotel so that
they would be safer together.
Image: Virgil Earp
At around midnight on December 28, 1881, Virgil
Earp was returning home to the hotel when
he was ambushed by several men carrying shotguns.
They unloaded three or four shots of buckshot
into him, hitting Virgil in the left arm,
hip, and groin.
He stumbled into the hotel and, against all
odds, the doctor managed to save his life,
although Virgil permanently lost the use of
his left arm.
His shooters were never identified, although
strong suspects included the remaining Clanton
brothers, Pete Spence, and Johnny Ringo.
Image: Morgan Earp
The reprisals were not over.
Almost three months later, Morgan Earp was
ambushed in a similar way.
On March 18, 1882, he was inside a billiards
parlor playing pool alongside Wyatt and a
few of their cohorts.
Shots came in through the window from one
or more unidentified assailants.
One of the bullets hit Morgan in the spine
and pierced his left kidney.
Another one hit the wall inches from Wyatt’s
head.
A doctor was brought in but it was clear that
the injuries were fatal.
According to Stuart Lake, Wyatt and Morgan
often talked about people having “visions
of heaven” on their deathbed and Morgan’s
last words were whispered in his brother’s
ear, saying “I can’t see a damn thing”.
Earp’s Vendetta Ride
In between the two attacks, Wyatt Earp had
been made deputy U.S. marshal to replace his
brother, Virgil, who was no longer able to
fulfil his duties.
After the first ambush, Earp still held out
hope that the system would deliver justice
to the men responsible.
However, there was a dearth of evidence, not
to mention the fact that any suspect had ten
other Cowboys ready to provide alibis for
them.
After Morgan was killed, Wyatt Earp realized
that he will not have justice, but he could
still have vengeance.
He embarked on a crusade where he gathered
a posse of men he trusted and who knew how
to handle a gun and set off to take out the
Cowboys.
It became known in western lore as Earp’s
vendetta ride.
It did not take long for Earp’s posse to
claim their first victim.
The day after Morgan’s death, his body was
put on a train and sent to Colton, California,
where his widow and parents were.
Also on the train were Virgil and his wife
who were leaving Tombstone as it simply became
too dangerous for them.
Image: Frank Stillwell
Wyatt received information that some of the
Cowboys were in Tucson where the train would
make a long stop.
He believed they were waiting to finish off
Virgil so he and his men accompanied them.
Indeed, the Cowboys were there, but made no
attempt on Virgil’s life as he was surrounded
at all times by five men armed to the teeth.
When his train departed, people heard multiple
gunshots coming from the train yard and saw
men running away from the scene.
Left behind they discovered the riddled body
of Frank Stillwell, a Cowboy and chief suspect
in Morgan’s murder.
According to Wyatt Earp’s version of events
given decades after the fact, he saw Stillwell
and Ike Clanton waiting in ambush on a flatcar
in the train yard.
He and his men went after them and the Cowboys
ran away, but Stillwell stumbled and got left
behind.
Earp caught up to him and discharged both
shotgun barrels into Stillwell when he tried
to grab the weapon.
The other gunmen shot Stillwell’s corpse
some more for good measure.
Image: Earp and Holliday statues where Stillwell
was killed
https://commons.wikimedia.org/wiki/File:Tucson-Amtrak_Station-1907-1922-2.JPG
Shockingly, even back in the Wild West, people
weren’t ok with Earp’s extra-judicial
killing.
Five men were indicted for Stillwell’s murder
and arrest warrants were issued for Wyatt
and Warren Earp, Doc Holliday, Sherman McMaster
and Jack “Turkey Creek” Johnson.
These five can be considered the original
members of the vendetta ride alongside “Texas
Jack” Vermillion who didn’t travel to
Tucson and stayed behind with the horses.
Dan Tipton and Charlie Smith joined them later.
Although they were now wanted men, the vendetta
ride continued into the Dragoon Mountains.
They caught up and killed a Cowboy named Florentino
Cruz who, according to Wyatt, served as lookout
the night of Morgan’s murder.
Unbeknownst to Earp, two other men suspected
of being involved, Pete Spence and an Indian
known as Hank, had already been arrested on
other charges.
Spence even turned himself in because he realized
it was safer in jail.
Image: Curly Bill Brocius
The vendetta ride ended with a bang in Iron
Springs in the Whetstone Mountains.
On March 24, 1882, they caught up to a Cowboys
posse that made camp there.
A shootout ensued and Earp recognized Curly
Bill Brocius as being among the gunmen.
According to Wyatt, he almost cut Brocius
in two with a double-barrel shotgun blast
to the stomach.
Another Cowboy named Johnny Barnes was also
killed in the gunfight although, miraculously,
none of Earp’s men were even injured.
There were still a few Cowboys who might have
been involved in the attacks on the Earps,
but they met their own violent, predictable
ends.
That same year, Billy Claiborne was killed
in Tombstone by “Buckskin” Frank Leslie.
Johnny Ringo was found dead of an apparent
suicide although, for obvious reasons, people
also suspected murder.
Phineas and Ike Clanton moved away and, a
few years later, were charged with cattle
rustling.
Phineas was taken in and Ike was killed resisting
arrest.
There were surprisingly few consequences for
Earp for his vendetta ride.
Some of the men were arrested, but released
on bail and they left the Arizona territory.
Further attempts to extradite them were unsuccessful.
Wyatt Earp moved to San Francisco with his
new partner, Josephine Marcus, and left the
Wild West behind.
Image: Dodge City Peace Commission
https://commons.wikimedia.org/wiki/File:DodgeCityPeaceCommission.jpg
In 1883, Earp made a brief return to his old
ways that is worthy of inclusion when his
friend and fellow gunfighter Luke Short asked
for his help in a conflict known as the Dodge
City War.
It ended up being bloodless and mostly uneventful,
but it is memorable for giving us one of the
most iconic photographs of the Wild West with
Short and his assembled posse.
Known as the Dodge City Peace Commission,
it included some of the west’s most famed
gunslingers such as Short himself, Wyatt Earp,
of course, Bat Masterson, and Charlie Bassett.
As you can probably tell, Wyatt Earp is the
one with the hat and moustache.
Fitzsimmons vs. Sharkey
In his post-Tombstone life, Earp tried his
hand in many ventures such as mining, oil,
horse racing, and saloon ownership.
He even served as a Hollywood consultant when
he lived in Los Angeles, but none of these
had memorable moments that need mentioning.
One job that did get the people talking big-time,
though, was his stint as a boxing referee.
In 1896, the boxing world was left without
a clear undisputed champion after the previous
titleholder, James J. Corbett, retired.
Eventually, one match scheduled for December
2 at the Mechanics Pavilion in San Francisco
would settle the matter.
The fighters were Tom Sharkey and Robert Fitzsimmons,
but organizers were having trouble finding
a referee that both sides accepted.
In the end, they offered the gig to Wyatt
Earp who had the experience and reputation.
The fight ended with a controversial finish
when Fitzsimmons hit Sharkey with a punch
in the 8th round.
Sharkey fell to the floor, clutching his groin
in agony.
Earp disqualified Fitzsimmons for a low blow
and gave the victory and the $10,000 purse
that came with it to Sharkey.
Image: “Bad Man” Referee caricature
https://commons.wikimedia.org/wiki/File:Bad_man_wyatt_earp_in_cartoon.png
The problem was that almost everyone else
saw the punch as a legitimate hit to the solar
plexus.
There was immediate talk of the match being
fixed with Earp in on the scam.
An injunction was placed on the money and
the fight moved to the courtroom.
Even though Earp was acquitted of any fixing
charges, he remained guilty in the eyes of
the public.
In his lifetime, this event severely denigrated
the reputation of Wyatt Earp and accusations
followed him until he died in 1929 of liver
disease at age 80.
It wasn’t until Lake published his biography
that Wyatt Earp regained a positive image,
although it was a fanciful and glowing account
that was only tangentially connected
to reality.